PROFESSOR: In this final
segment on predicate logic,
there are two issues that
I'm going to talk about.
The first is some problems with
translating A E quantifiers
and E A quantifiers
into English-- or rather
from English into logic.
We've seen examples in class
that English is ambiguous.
And I want to show you
two that are I think
interesting and provocative.
Just as a warning that
the translation is not
always routine.
And then the second
topic is an optional one,
just to kind of
make some comments
about the amazing results
in metamathematics,
the mathematics of
mathematics, or more
precisely, the mathematics
of mathematical logic.
And two fundamental
theorems about properties
of predicate calculus,
which go beyond this class
and are optional,
I would suggest
it's worth listening to
the A E in English example.
And if you want to skip the
short discussion of the meta
theorems, that's fine,
because it's never going
to come up again in this class.
So let's look at this phrase in
English, where the poet says,
"all that glitters is not gold."
Well, a literal
translation of that
would be that, if we
let G be glitters,
and I can't use G again,
so we'll say Au is gold,
then this translated literally
would say for every x,
G of x, if x is gold
implies that not gold of x.
So is that a
sensible translation?
Well, it's clearly
false, because gold
glitters like gold.
And you can't say
that gold is not gold.
So this is not what's meant.
It's not a good translation.
It doesn't make sense.
Well, what is meant,
well, when the poet says,
"all that glitters
is not gold," he's
really leaving out a key word
to be understood from context.
All that glitters is
not necessarily gold.
He was using poetic license.
You're supposed to fill in
and understand its meaning.
And the proper
translation would be
that it is not true that
everything that glitters
is gold.
It is not the case that
for all x, if x glitters,
then x is gold.
So it's just an example
where a literal translation
without thinking about
what the sentence means
and what the poet who
articulated this sentence
intended will get you
something that's nonsense.
It's one of the problems
with machine translation
from natural language into
precise formal language.
Let's look at another
example of the same kind.
The poet says this
time, "there is a season
to every purpose under heaven."
This is a variant of
a biblical phrase.
So what does it mean?
Well, the literal
translation would
be, there exists an
s that's a season,
such that for every p that's
a purpose, s is for p.
Well, that from the way
the quantifiers work
means that there's some season,
say summer, that's supposed
to be good for all purposes.
Well, that's not right,
because summer is not
good for snow shoveling.
And if your purpose is to
shovel snow, then summer
will not do for you as a season.
So even though
it's phrased, there
is a season to every
purpose under heaven,
it's not the case that the
intended translation is there
is a season for every purpose.
In fact, the poet really means
to flip the quantifiers, which
is what's shown here.
We're going to switch them
around so that we are really
saying, for every purpose,
there is a season,
such that s is for p.
For snow shoveling,
winter is good.
For planting, spring is good.
For leaf watching, fall is good.
And that is, in fact,
the intended translation
here, although I
remind you that there's
a famous historical man, Sir
Thomas More, who was described
as a man for all seasons.
That would be a case where
there was one man who
was good for all seasons.
He was a polymath--
a writer, a cleric,
and the chancellor of
England for many years
until he had a falling
out with Henry VIII, which
served him ill.
That's the end of those two
examples, whose point is just
to warn you that translation
from English into math
is not something
that can be done
in a mindless mechanical way.
Sometimes, the
quantifiers really
are meant to go the
other way from the way
that they literally appear.
Now, we're going to shift to
another topic, which is just
two profound theorems
from mathematical logic
about the properties
of predicate calculus
that are worth
knowing about and that
describes sort of the
power and limits of logic.
So these are called
meta-theorems,
because they're
theorems about theorems.
They're theorems about
systems for proving theorems.
And that phrase, meta, means
going up above a level.
So the first theorem
is a good news theorem.
It says that, if you
want to be able to prove
every valid assertion
of predicate calculus,
there really is only
a few axioms and rules
that will do the job.
As a matter of fact,
the rules that you need
are just rules that
we've seen already,
namely modus ponens and
universal generalization
and a few valid axioms
which we've seen already.
So let's go back a little bit.
So there's a remark here
that says that, in practice,
if you're really going to try
to do automatic theorem proving,
you need much more than
this minimal system.
But it's intellectually
interesting and satisfying
that a fairly economical set
of axioms and inference rules
are in theory
sufficient to prove
every logically valid sentence.
And this is known as Godel's
completeness theorem.
Godel was the great
mathematician,
German mathematician, who spent
the latter part of his life
at the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton
as an emigre.
And he has two major
theorems, at least,
that are results of his.
One is the completeness
theorem-- this one.
Then there's an incompleteness
theorem, which maybe we'll
talk about in a few lectures.
But for now, the good news is
you can prove everything that's
valid using a few simple rules.
Now, the bad news
is that there's
no way to tell
whether you're attempt
to find a proof for
something that you think
is valid is going to succeed.
There's no way to
test whether or not
a quantified formula is valid.
This is in contrast to the
case of propositional formulas,
where you can do it
with a truth table.
A truth table may
blow up, so it becomes
pragmatically infeasible.
But at least,
theoretically, there's
an exhaustive search
that will enable
you to figure out whether a
propositional formula is valid.
That's not the case
with predicate calculus.
Predicate calculus
is undecidable,
meaning that it's logically
impossible to write a computer
program that will take an
arbitrary predicate calculus
formula in and print out
true or false depending on
whether or not it's valid.
Can't be done.
Now, as I said, we're
not going to go further
into these theorems.
These are the kind
of basic results
that would be proved in an
introductory course in logic.
Usually, they take about
a half a term to do,
maybe a little less.
And it goes beyond our course.
You can look over in
the math department
for introductory
courses in logic.
And you will learn about these
two profound meta-theorems
about logic and math.